moi j'en est vrai à raymond l'abominable
homme de rungis
selon mes informations exclusives il en
train de négocier avec vos équipes une
augmentation pas piquée des hannetons
mais et c'est clairement en train de lui
monter à la tête duranleau j'adore mais
hier je les vire là j'étais en train de
crier à moi la moue lives et comme ça
que des billets et
[Musique]
ce à quelques minutes après ils étaient
des pièces à
produire tu veux rien négocié négocie
sur une augmentation à s'était vite
faire alors je peux te donner les noms
ce comptage il eu la réponse à ce
constat dit je suis rentré dans le
bureau de lionel tardy directeur de
l'adt h2o alors je suis rentré j'ai
déterminé jeudi quand même il faut que
je sois un peu un petit peu plus
augmenté parce que je la même chose dans
le camion de la même chose qu'ici c'est
pas possible sauf que ça roulait avec
des arrêts voilà je vais y aller avec
des arguments n'ont pas traîné et alors
j'ai rencontré des plus gros écrevisses
de
montfa sait jusqu'où cela dans le slip
déchiré violente et griffé dans le dos
j'ai passé plus de temps dans
l'ascenseur bloqué parce que faut un
badge que à négocier avec lui je suis
ressorti
ils m'ont dit pour le temps que tu
passes sur le plateau tu te rends compte
la chance que tu as et vous êtes
croissante et le sourire aux
lèvres avec un café j'ai croisé des gens
que je connaissais ni bonjour agatha tu
vas faire quoi non j'étais passé comme
ça
mais nos spécialistes garder
[Applaudissements]
chroniqueur n'hésitez pas vous aussi à
passer
vous serez toujours bien reçus et à bien
négocier parce que là tu repars avec un
peu moins ils arrivent à être condamnée
mais en fait c'est d'argent mais
voilà bah non c'est des tee shirts et
des tueurs sont réunis avec un peu un
bon gars que tu touche aujourd'hui elle
regarde ce que tu touches avant
d'entamer regarde aujourd'hui mais qui
est en jeu c'est
là également et sébastien par
puisqu'aucun aussi
j'aimerais revenir à qui chivu dans le
vrai et 50% du salaire en soi alors trop
chaining trop de visagiste trop de
coloriste trop de week-end avec des
plans prometteur dans des chambres
d'hôtel blizzard
vient de lanton et encore 50% c'est
c'est cher alors je vous demande est
maintenant de le faire à visage
découvert et de noter sur une ardoise
vous allez avoir dix secondes chacun
pour noter le nom et beinheim revenez
sur votre argent votre avis dix secondes
vont doter celui qui vaut 50 % de moins
et vous nous dites pourquoi s'il vous
plaît vraiment une musique de suspense
je vais démarrer
par celui
qui a toujours le coeur ouvert
mais les yeux fermés
celui qu'on appelle la mèche rebelle
dans le milieu
celui
ça va vous soit vous écoute tout datant
de samedi durieux sur ce qu'il s'est
passé ma gueule je sais
en coulisses et nice et c'est très beau
et on perd comme disait mort oui la
vérité château et vérité je vous le dis
je le noir dit j'adore la ne changeait
pas ben je t'ai pas demandé pour la vie
à toi c'est pas mal du tout ben on aime
beaucoup tous les jours il faut vraiment
le mettre en confiance parce que cette
pêche est très belle journée d'été
confiance un peu c'est vrai j'ai mené ma
joue
sa joie roja par poil sur le caillou
mois qu'il émerge dans le slip
petit top cet
e-tron ce titre devrait bientôt de
quelques dizaines de mètres dans le site
ces titres
offrent pour qu'elle bat à et alors je
nettoyais toujours hyper sympa les gars
là oui je vais expliquer pourquoi sauf
que delphine lui parlait bien fort ils
ont fait des films dans très peu de
temps peut-être trois quatre jours
peut-être quelque chose ne va pas les
plus pressés au microclimat l'embarras
panon cet accueil qui marche
hier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et les gens
[Applaudissements]
oui bon pourquoi parce que dans quelques
jours quelques jours quelques semaines
on le sait elle va hériter et roger
s'il brille c'est horrible mais servir
de tout ce que vous dites est vrai qu
dhabi c'est drôle moi c'était pour faire
la mettant en exergue en exergue les
méchants et méchant à ces gens crise
touche aux familles il m'écrit et vous
écrire oui mais crime il dit quoi ma
gueule
non mais sans rire mais vous avez vu ce
nom battu le maire yves bordés son avis
à chaque fois cette espèce d'enfoiré la
wii à chaque mois pour pokémon début
j'entendais quelqu'un d'autre guillaume
l'a clairement fait un bad buzz
[Rires]
vous êtes de yens il ya deux ans
regardez géraldine pas c'est super chaud
quand elle avait 3 y est stationné
regardez on va regarder le dos d'âne
l'ont ralenti le rythme merci et daniel
c'est moche c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment nul
[Rires]
je peux venir
non non c'est toi avec elle c'est pirna
est-ce que tu pas allé
au studio
te bats de l'onu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors pas mis sur la
[Rires]
table et c'est clairement un bad buzz un
mois sur les réseaux c'est un
déferlement un déferlement gouët un
déferlement peuple est modique en pis ça
va vous sinon ça va très bien je passe
un très bon dès le début d'émission
qu'on aime ou on fait des compliments
magnifique j'adore j'adore cette
perfusion de boules je souhaitais une
joueuse hors d une émission triomphal à
willow 6 à 7 très beau score
façon parce que moi aussi je vote
je trouve que c'est un chroniqueur qui
s'est un peu voilà avons choisi laurent
et depuis qu'il a des nouveaux yeux et
nouvelle mèche il mise tout sur son
physique et du coup ils donnent plus son
opinion sur
ce qu'on a une belle poitrine
qu'on doit pas non mais c'est vrai qu'on
a quand même sa personne mais
franchement delphine donc c'est le
bonheur à gaza dit il mérite moins 50%
oui parce qu'en ce moment il est un peu
sur le soit beau et tais toi comme ça y
parle parce qu'ils étaient surtout sur
le haut des toits
criaient ils alors
duret comme un connard ces vandales
[Applaudissements]
la supporter
les émissions
[Rires]
super
beau genton il est tellement mauvais
qu'avec lui même les chroniqueurs les
plus inutiles n'est ce pas benjamin
[Rires]
allez monter ta poitrine à tout le monde
on leur a dû cul c'est moi qui paye des
sens à leur vie
calmez vous
mais toi tu te calmes et je veux dire à
[Rires]
séoul à le micro pénis s'énerve
alors des santois ses gains
et c'est fera de ces pics
tu veux vraiment qu'on parle d'eux est
non alors s'il vous plaît qui roulait
alors on peut pas évidemment mais je
n'ai pas java web je le répète n'a pas
petit si tous que tu désires pas demain
il a malheureusement tout prix de sa
mère
et sabu va très bien
non mais arrêtez on rigole haleine ses
interventions et je vous le dit les yeux
dans les yeux guillaume vos
interventions sont aussi dégueulasse que
vos tenues
evènement dès maintenant à genton le
loup le renard
[Applaudissements]
t on embrasse
manon soir que man dans la vallée de
danane
je les embrasse ses murs garde alors
gilles pourquoi est-ce que c'est ignoble
laura ne dépense jamais son argent il se
lave jamais les cheveux il porte la même
baisse depuis le premier test
alors ça tire à balles réelles
mais l'équipe a
oui toi t'es vraiment un connard
vient se prosterner en loge quoi en
disant [ __ ] et de moi j'ai été mauvais
hier j'ai pas dit un mot cyril va me
jeter c'était avant-hier soir il est
venu me dire tu as vu j'ai pas dit un
mot mathieu a pris ma place j'ai plus
rien j'ai même pu doc j'ai rien tu veux
que je t'aide et maintenant tu me
balance voilà ce qui ferait juste c'est
vrai que vous avez la même baisse depuis
le premier débat sur ses vrais amis mais
non vous savez comme reste c'est moi je
vous le voulez plus non
c'est vrai c'est qu'il n'est pas les
personnes qui sont à côté vous ne le
voit pas
le jour vous avez les mêmes écarts huard
est
le gars c'est 50 mg au paddle pardon à
105 anticipées
bon voilà alors moi je vais faire un peu
à contre-courant et s'adapte et de
générosité accouché en fait je demande
en examen qui elle peut accoucher cette
[ __ ]
je vais demander qu'on se tomber le dise
mon salaire par deux
seulement à isabelle comme solde de tout
compte isabelle si tu leur donnes
retraite
là
la cohésion
[Applaudissements]
c'est la série b webo et à la famille
des sites où l'on dormait
c'est fou non
c'est par là elles il allait la fin de
sa fiesta
on sera dans un instant ce qu'elle est à
ce que l'on pense à deux aces et créera
certainement tout cas
elle est méchante elle est allée à la
famille sortez nous avons
aimé arriver changer d'avis cause de ça
mais moi toujours j'entends un arrêt qui
doit se concentrer sur sur l'aide
est vraiment est vraiment écrit ben
ouais ça s'écrit comme ça non classés
doit se concentrer sur l'être oui elle a
oublié la voix reprend il y en avoir
dans quel magasin qui pensent qu à
posséder acheter des voitures
et des montres des bagues des lunettes
posséder un consumérisme un peu maladif
qui cache quelque chose d'intimé rythme
je donne sa langue au sens de mes
cachets à l'association coloris sans
frontières
a trouvé un balayage de qualité
qui irait très bon bonsoir et bonsoir
vous avez une très belle veston dubuc et
bien
non mais je vais faire en 10 secondes on
a la chance d'avoir un professeur qui
vient de temps en temps nous éclairer
sur l'île sur les vaccins à virologie
celle qu'on avait autrefois kelly vdev
litres à distance qui nous éclaire aussi
sur les vaccins mais on a un troisième
docteur sûrement la place qu'il fait ça
delphine avec qui est maintenant docteur
aussi dans les missions qui me parle
beaucoup du vaccin donc je veux diviser
son salaire par deux vu qu'elle docteur
maintenant
j'ai jamais dit que les docteurs je
donne juste la voix de ceux qui ne se
font pas actuellement
l'impression qu'on s'est trompés ils
sont encore plus méchant que c'est fou
hein mais j'aime bien rémi délatté
réalité la vérité cyril
[Applaudissements]
j'ai voulu dire la vérité je vais dire
ça mérite mais ça vous a échappé quand
même
raymond sera pour deux
éminents reposer un petit peu
reçois beaucoup de lettres de personnes
se disant est ce que les chroniqueurs
qui ne sont pas là trois jours de suite
sont définitivement perdus alors je
réponds téléspectateurs ces noms de nom
on peut ne pas être là pendant ces trois
jours trois semaines trois mois trois
ans
donc à la norme sepa mais revenir donc
ne vous inquiétez pas je le dis à vous
tous quand vous n'êtes pas appelé mais
c'est parfois pour mieux vous rappelez
moi y ait ou pas je vous le dis je le
répète c'est vérifier exactement garder
mathieu mais parti faire le gendarme
exactement non non j'en ai tout à faire
de l'ordre dans l'esprit de mes faire
plein de choses
il préfère acteurs oui tout à fait je
vais faire du théâtre ah oui tout à fait
- il est resté chez lui après celle qui
tue
force qu'il a maintenant qu'il est à
découvrir à garder la force quidam c'est
vrai
qu'il a découvert c'est vrai que c'est
quelqu'un qui donne beaucoup absolument
est ce qu'on vous dit de l'analyse de
raymond n'a pas tort
brillant elle m'ennuie j'ai déjà passé à
autre chose je peux donner mon nom a
bien sûr
genton j'entends le loup le renard
[Applaudissements]
le problème maintenant c'est quand il va
se balader
quelque part je vous ai deux baguettes
pour qu'ils tuent pour j'entends
[Applaudissements]
je l'entends je te la fais courte depuis
je fais toujours cours cette invention
par émission c'est une minute trente une
minute 42 surgelés bonjour et au revoir
donc franchement tu es nul et tu feras
même passé pernikoff pour un bon
chroniqueur peut dégager merci au
fait qu'il appliquait déjà le site et
père du corps qui est un ami ouais c'est
dans les mines qui n'a rien
[Musique]
lâché à nico
elle va revenir qu'à les voir là à ce
qu'a rappelé pour être meilleur j'ai
trouvé chambre à vous allez me limite et
là il ya la taille a été trop loin je
m'assois méchant anonyme d'il ya trop de
gens qui pour sa couleur
jusqu'au temps pense d'abord ben alors
certes non mais tu veux le changement
s'est reproduit ralenti mais ce que j'en
pense
mais ça il fait une rentrée 2022 calme
ghana d'accord voilà c'est bien ça y est
tu as quelque chose à lui répond
quelqu'un peut me respecter pour
être respectés ici bon alors tu fais
exactement respecté ainsi c'est parce
qu'il est fort on va suivre est
simple à quoi je reçois plein de
messages pour me dire que guillaume il a
trouvé sa place que maintenant dans les
débats il est très très fort qui me dis
les choses très justes s'cusez moi mais
wayne avait des messages
ma mère ce que ça vous dit tout c'est
pas vraiment une bonne nouvelle ma mère
m brasse la mère de raymond vous adorent
fait merci sachez qu'elle n'a pas la
télévision